elle fait ça la semaine
dernière. Je lui ai parlé il y a
quelques minutes.
Caroline Côté, bonsoir.
CAROLINE CÔTÉ,
aventurière et cinéaste
aventure que je viens de vivre.
Je crois que je voyais cette
aventure-là comme quelque chose
de... de possible. Je gégégégég.
Et je suis bien contente
de revenir. Ça fait deux jours
que je suis revenue sur
la petite vill C C C C C C C C .
- Vous vous reposez au Chili,
sur la pointe du Chili, qui est
la plus proche du pôle Sud,
d'une
on a demandé, en 1924, à George
Mallory, un alpiniste,ouourquoi
il voulait aller au sommet de
l'Everest, il a
que c'est là", tout simplement.
Qu'est-ce qui vous motivait
d'aller au pôle Sud,
et d'aller plus vite que
to
- Déjà, l'Antarctique, aller
là-bas, on se rend compte que
c'est un lieu qui est trèsststùi
est en nous. On va voir quion et
de le faire solitairement aussi,
c'était un défi que je voulais
me lancer. Quand est-ce que,
dans la vie, on a l'opportunité
de faire ça, de se retrouver
seul pendant 30 jours ou plus?
Et ça m'a impressionnée,
ça m'a étonnée. Et ce n'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose
que je referai. Parce que
de ne jamais avoir de gens
autour de nous pour nous appuyer
ou nous dire qu'on peut aller
un peu plus loin, c'est...
ça a été un bon défi,
justement, d'être seule.
- Racontez-moi. Bon, vousrtrtrt.
Alors, vous partez. Et l
qu'est-ce qui devient, jour
après jour, le plu
Est-ce que c'est tout
simplement le fr
- C'est... c'est sûr que
le froid fait
défi se complique à chaque jour.
Donc, on par........... à un
niveau très bas, près de la mer.
Donc on a
d'environ -13, -14°. Et plus
on alululululus on avance,
on se rend à des températures
fin, au pôle, j'avais des -34.
Et ouvrir la porte de sa petite
tente le matin, c'est plus
difficile. P
assez constant et qui arrive
en pleine face du sud.
C'es
Ensuite, bien, il y a le fait
de savoir que tout mon
j'y fasse vraiment attention
pa
j'ai. Mon traîneau, en fait,
c'est ma demeure. C'est ce que
plus proche du pôle, et il faut
que je fasse attention à ce
que... à ce que j'apporte avecm.
- Racoàààààà quel moment,
vraiment, les embûches,
simplement, ont fait en sorte
qu'à un moment donné, vous vous
êtes dit : "Peut-être que
À quel moment vous vous êtes
dit : "Oh là là, je suis
embarquée dans quelque choseusue
que je croyais encore"?
- Ouf! Déjà, chaque jour,
de faire 35 km environ, c'est
que j'avais avec moi, c'était
k k k k k k kg, et je devais
le traîner... Donc, chaque jour
je me demandaie e e e e e e e e.
Avec, c'e e e e e e e vent, les
sastrugi, qui sont des espèces
et la température qui baisse,
je dirais que... au milieu de
l'aventure, c'était envi
seule. Je voyais devant moiFFFFs
seule. Je voyais devant moi'i'i.
Puis, c'est à ce moment-là quej,
de toute façon, je suis là, j'ai
la chance d'être en Antarctique,
pourquoi pas y aller à fond
et donner tout ce que j'ai?"
Et finalement, bien, j'ai su
m'attendre au pôle Sud, puis
j'ai vu son avion qui passait
pour aller me rejoindre.
de continuer, évidemment.lllllùé
d'efforts jusqu'à l'arrivée.
- Wow! Et parlououououououououoé
du nombre de kilos que vous
aviez dû transporter. Si jamais
une fixation devait céder, vousz
du matériel. Vous aviez...
Il y a plein de défis
techniques, du matériel aussir..
- Exactement. En fait, c'est
ce qui s'est produit. Mon ski
détachée. Il faut devenir un p
réparateur ou technicien de tout
bonne colle. On s'entend
que le fameux Duck Tape, on en
Sinon, bien, le ré
il fallait que j'en prenne soin.
panneau solair
ski. C'est des choses que j'aiee
de voyager telle
pour avoir le moins de poids
j'ai seulement une paire de ski,
j'ai seulement un réchaud,
par exemple. Et tout ça fait ent
deererererererererererer
jusqu'au bout de l'aventure.
- Évidemment... vous ne
rencontrez évidemment personne,
ça, il va sans dire, mais
vous rencontrez aucun animal,
aucune vie. Est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose qui a bougé
pendant les 34 jours?
- C'était incroyable.
On reste vraiment avec sa tête,
très seul. Là-bas, c'est blanc
et c'est le soleil qui est
présent avec nous durant toute
la journée, qui fait un tour
complet. Parce qu'il y a pas
de n s s s s s s s s s s soleil
à droite, et ensuite, ça se
déplace à gauche, et c'est
eueueueueueueueueueueueux qui
aiment la nuit, bien, il y en a
aucune là-bas. Je suis arrivéeùu
le ciel noir. Mais aucun animal,
puisqu'on est un peu trop haut.
J'ai pas vu d'oiseaux
et vraiment rien de vivant
jusqu'à l'arrivée au pôle.ezezet
rare qu'on se retrouve avec soi-
même pendant 30 jours et plus.
En plus, vous aviez des défis
quotidiens. Qu'est-ce que
vous avez découvert de vous?
- Ouf! Bien, ça, il faut que
je fasse encore un bon... un bon
constat dans les prochains
jours. C'est sûr qu'il y
une force intérieure qui vient
avec l'aventure que je viens de
vivre. Tu sais, on dit
ah, bien, tu sais, l'ego m'a
permis d'aller plus loin. Puis,
dans mon aventur
s'est passé. Au jour 3, ce qui
m'a permis d'aller plus loin,
c'est pas né
de dire que je voulais faire
cette grande expédition-là,
mais c
que j'aime autour de moi
qui me permettaient d'avoir
le courage de continuer.
- Et en terminant, deux
questions. Qu'est-ce que vous
allez... Bon, il y aura un film,
qu'est-c
quel est le débouché
documentaire de votre mission?
- Alors, malheureusement, j'ai
paagagagagagagagagagagagagagages
de ce beau défi là parce que
j'étais dans un effort constant.
J'ai quelques vidéos que je vait
minime comparé aux documentaires
que je fais habituellement sur
d'autres expéditions. Donc,
il y a un livre et certainement
un balado qui va venir
avec cette épreuve-là, qui,
j'espère, va pouvoir mettre
les gens dans le bain,
dans l'ambiance de ce que
j'ai vécu en Antarctique.
- Le dépassement à ce niveau-là,
à ces niveaux-là, est-ce que ça
ndndndndndndndndndndndndndndndae
à trouver un autre défi ensuite?
Que vous ne pouvez pas arrêter?
- Bien, évidemment, le domaine
de l'aventure, c'est un peu ça.
C'est po
que j'ai toujours envie
de continuer, parce qu'on fait
des
expédition sur qui on est
vraiment. Et, bon, je peux dire
au pôle, j'ai dit à Vincent,
mon conjoint, que c'étaitssssssà
autre chose, que j'allais rester
pas mal à la maison. Donc, c'est
ce qui s'est passé. Par contre,
plus j'avais de sommeil
accumulé, donc plus je pouvais
me reposer ici en ville, bien,
je suis déjà en train
de planifier quelques...
quelques autres aventures. Mais
il faut rester prudent, il faut
rester prudent, il faut pas
aller trop loin aussi. Cette
expédition-là m'a pris beaucoup
d'énergie, donc le repos fait
partie aussi du système
de comment on repart, oui.
- Très bien. Caroline Côté,
c'est un exemple, en tout cas,
pour beaucoup de gens, ce
dépassement-là, le goût detututr
dehors, le goût de découvrir, le
goût de se pousser aux limites.
Merci beaucoup de nous avoirpar.
- Merci beaucoup à vous! Bonne
fin de soirée, tout le monde